if the Chiefs lose I won't eat
McDonald's anymore ever ever what yeah
wait wait whoa that's crazy it's crazy
that's that's how confident I am no no
no I feel like the equivalent of that
bet is like $5 million I like McDonald's
is probably watching this like what the
hell okay matter of fact this is rated
PG right this is rated PG you say what
you want it's like Disney you can say
what you want for matter of fact if if
the chief
lose I'll divorce my wife and no more
sex for the rest of the
year that's a lot you're putting on this
I mean that's how confident I am so no
McDonald's a divorce divorce and no sex
and she's right there she's right there
and yeah I don't care